so ronnie the limo driver he had coveted
did you know that what
yeah how bad did let's be lit to give me
the update how bad was it run i had uh
a low-grade fever
uh which was that didn't bother me much
but i had this a sore throat like i
never had in my life
it was like somebody took a fireball and
dumped it down my throat it was wow i
couldn't stop coughing first of all let
me say how i knew you were gonna have
covered because right as we were taking
the break i pointed out ronnie's throat
sounded scratchy and i said you got
covered you sound hung over you drinking
last night
no
you got a cold you're cold something's
going on no i was out i was out in the
sun yesterday
my throat is real dry
and i goggled with it
and i heard you couldn't have sex um you
were so sick like you dude no
see like normally if i'm
if i'm sick like i get a cold or
something and if i'm like even i'm
taking some kind of
cold medicine
for some reason that horns me up like
unfucking believable hmm
my dick was dead during this whole time
oh
is it true that is it true
that uh stephanie sent you a sexy video
yeah well
it was kind of like in the shower i mean
it was great but it was worthless to me
i couldn't do anything let me understand
something she was showering and she put
the the video on and said hey ronnie
yeah i know you're laying there sick so
i'm gonna send you a sexy video yeah she
did well she came see i didn't even
really see her much
because i was in i was like in in the
guest bedroom and i was locked yeah
isolating she didn't get it so which you
know worked out
you know right yeah right
but she decided to send you this little
yeah she came in she said oh i made
something for you and i said okay
and then i looked at it it was great but
nothing man my dick was dead i couldn't
smell anything did you get yourself
yeah it's starting to come back i i
didn't lose my taste though that was
good when did it come back when i
started feel better are you back to
[ __ ] oh yeah yeah